good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday another
beautiful day in the queue hey Claude
hiya nerd I'm doing okay I'm starting to
feel triggered by how you turn but I'm
not one ever to tell you what to do or
say cuz you are a woman and I empower
you to speak your feelings some people
in the comments don't necessarily agree
but it's okay just there's two types of
people in this world people who are
triggered by it and people whose day
like apparently can't start without it
apparently they're saying it to their
friends like I've been getting so much
feedback on how you do really
overwhelmingly when I posted that
screenshot of the person writing to me
like please never stop saying it I just
posted a screenshot I looked at it
yesterday I looked at the reactions that
people had sent me from it I had over
200 claps I've never gotten that many
reactions I have only seen the negative
so it's easy for me to you know dive
into that but if you're saying people
are loving it I believe you and I have
no choice but to respect that you know
that if people like we're hating it and
I knew that like I would stop saying it
because I just like care what people
think about me um and I just would not
do something to intentionally bother
people and turn them off to the show but
apparently like it's become just a
staple for some people and the media
don't try implement it we have no choice
but to implement I would just like to
say I'm wearing some merch from my tour
it says dirty jeans to are available at
shop morning toast comm along with a
host of other items some of which are on
sale so make sure to take advantage shop
morning toast comm you know what I
actually don't have any djt merch like
that I need to place an order you need
to place an order I um before quarantine
like remember when I was talking about
um the game night like when we didn't
know quarantine was legit I'm like
should I have a game night and that I
did it was like literally the beginning
of March yeah everyone came over and was
drinking and they were talking about
toast march like I don't have any it's
like I gave away all my merch like
literally everything my shelves were
cleared so I recently did a major haul
from our website and it's just I don't
know what I would do without toast merch
in the queue I know everyone's been
getting their spring worth which is so
exciting there was a little hiccup with
some orders some Thai Thai shirts they
were quote
by the mill yeah they just like whirring
worth sending out to you guys so people
got refunds for those orders we're so
sorry that that happened these are hard
times otherwise we'd be able to make new
shirts but inventory is low so instead
of being getting a replacement you got a
refund we're doing the best that we can
in the queue but we apologize for that
snafu and we couldn't help the big old
stain what do you want to share it with
the stain yeah it's just it was a stain
II vibe and it wasn't up to par and so
we weren't gonna send it out but we do
have some exciting merch things
happening we were just on a call
yesterday I'm so [ __ ] pumped for
what's coming next and I think
everyone's gonna be really into it so
that's exciting update I'll give you a
clue for the new merch category is I
like guns extra guns its elegant as [ __ ]
is that from friends or something
yes that's from friends no it's from
RuPaul's Drag Race like elegant
extravagance is like when you get
dressed out up like the ultimate glamour
high-fashion makeup glam that's eleganza
extravaganza nice okay very cool um I'm
very much here for you quoting RuPaul's
Drag Race instead of friends like ya
know I feel like my cool factor and like
just so many things about me have
changed and gone up so much since I
started watching RuPaul's Drag Race like
everything is just sickening and I'm
gagging the house down oh I forgot to
tell you over the weekend I watched
celebrity drag race which is like a
lettuce spin-off where each episode they
have three celebrities compete for
celebrity drag race it's all for charity
it's like not really serious they have
some of the Queens from seasons past
come and mentor the celebrities so I
watched the most interesting episode
which was um Phoebe Robinson from two
dub Queens we love a podcaster Hayley
kiyoko and Madison beer it was so
fascinating Hayley kiyoko ended up
winning which I was so happy for her
because she really deserved it then the
next episode I watched was Vanessa
Williams oh my god
Wilhemina apparently her Andrew our
friends so she won she would have won
anyways like she really leaned into it
like she
got in the glam and they did this whole
performance it was a Dolly Parton theme
and she looked she was singing nine to
five like she really dove headfirst and
you get to pick your drag name and her
name was vanquish of the house like she
was just she obviously watches drag race
and she was like so in it and so happy
to be there it was fabulous to see her
like in that element wow that's so
exciting when you were saying Vanessa
first I was singing from Gossip Girl and
then I was thinking from Blue Bloods so
it just took me a while to realize like
what you were saying no Vanessa Williams
Wilhemina queen of the world she was out
your wedding no queen of the world she's
literally the queen of my world in the
queue like if I ever need premium
content to watch I'll just go to her
IMDB and pick something you know if I
ever need premium content I will scroll
through my phone and find the picture
you and I took him with her at your
wedding where I literally look so ugly
but I don't care no I know like it's not
a cute picture but it's everything of
the sort where does she live um in the
New York area Oh cuz you know me she
wouldn't fit in but if she looked in
that Beverly Hills she would actually be
a fabulous addition to Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills but I think she's too
good for the women of New York she
cannot these women are stepped down I
would agree with that yeah okay I
watched Beverly Hills this morning
[ __ ] DVR didn't record it and I felt
like I was on a deserted island I could
not find it anywhere usually they play
it right after watch repens live again
no yeah anyway like I was so annoyed and
they don't put it on um like Apple TV or
iTunes till the next morning
it was so much drama but I ended up
waking up early watching it today but I
know you didn't watch it because you
were doing the redhead so we will recap
it tomorrow okay a few things one yes I
was working on the redheads we finished
recording at around 6:30 and I was legit
working on it like having my dinner at
my computer until midnight because that
audio just like getting it premium it
makes the book club experience just so
much more experiential and it was such a
good episode because the book was a
level up we leveled up and Dana was
there to explain it all and you know
what I feel like I got a little bit
beneath the surface like for me and I
feel like my mind is expanding as well
so I think this book club is just great
for everyone but there's something for
everyone there's Dana who's obvious was
the best book we ever chose and there's
snitch who came close to writing in a 0
so if you were
any of those levels like you will feel
represented and it's just fabulous but I
didn't have time to watch Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills because I
was staring at my computer all day I was
working all day yesterday it was crazy
and then I just couldn't turn on my TV
and get that blue light and I needed to
go to sleep I was exhausted I understand
it was a really good episode it was
essentially for me like it was the
episode of Erika Jayne like there was
just so much happening around her about
her since the event happened at her
house like we never really get to see
her in her home element that much so I
think you'll really enjoy the episode
there was a ton of drama we got to know
Garcelle a little bit more I really
can't wait to recap it um we'll do that
tomorrow with New York and you want to
say Oh what were you gonna say no in
today's week TV recaps Eggman I'm going
to be recapping than plots Netflix
special because I have thoughts
okay then I'm putting you on mute
because they did not have time to watch
that I didn't have time to watch so many
things that I love that like you know
the passion project had to come first
and I want to say um in a very sad just
thing you should know for the day in an
alternate world we would have been
embarking on camp toast today so that's
just like something to make you upset no
we would have been it's okay so it's a
lump 15 we would have been finishing the
toast in like 15 minutes
packing the car and driving yeah Campos
would start tomorrow but we would be on
our way up there today like starting the
vlog last year we hit up CPK on our way
like we would just be like in the car
with Theo sitting in traffic um like on
our way and that's just something that's
gonna haunt me all day one of my
favorite memories of camp toasts past
was the day we got to spend a camp like
totally alone before like running around
camp like we were like running the place
I'm like so upset
no it's devastating there's absolutely
nowhere else I would rather be right now
like if I could transport myself right
now to any situation um outside the
queue it would be camp toast like that
is the vibe that I am craving like it
wouldn't be a concert it wouldn't be
stagecoach like it would be the scene II
vibes of camp toast like surrounded by
the love of the toasters and a very
beautiful bucolic setting do you think
that the rescheduled dates for Coachella
and stagecoach are going to stay as is I
don't I'm going to be optimistic
has been my mentality throughout the
queue I'm going to remain optimistic
every time they give us a date I'm
optimistic that that's the real date and
that's the only way I can cope is by
really believing what the what they say
is true okay that's a good way to think
yeah um I had one more thing to say
about camp toasts but oh no about the
word bucolic now that I just use that in
my everyday jargon what if we did a word
of the day and then we just like we're
getting smarter and then we saw if we
could use it in in the episode what do
you think about that I mean Oh in the
episode that's actually a good idea
sweeten it up the episode like we would
say at the top of the episode the word
of the day and then we would try and
have to find a way to incorporate it
into the episode and like all of our
vocabularies would be expanding I love
that idea that's so smart and I'm just
gonna go to merriam-webster's word of
the day
it's a cowcatcher an inclined frame on
the front of a railroad locomotive for
throwing obstacles off track okay so
maybe like it's a deterrent like yes
something that's you know just throws
things through a loop yes so like if I
was recapping Beverly Hills I could say
like the astrologist was a real
cowcatcher to the group okay cool so
let's try and use it okay we'll try and
use it in a story so I let's get into it
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but if I may can
I say some please we've got that
attitude today's episode is brought to
you by attitude sheets we know that
sleep plays an important role in our
physical mental and emotional health and
research shows that adequate sleep helps
our bodies fight off infection at a time
when our well-being is more important
than ever there's a company we want to
tell you about that's working to help
you to commit to a healthy approach to
sleep
it's called attitude while there are
many factors that contribute to cease to
a sound sleep optimizing your
environment is one way to help attitudes
clean bamp bamboo bedding and sleep
essentials are 100% organic and designed
to bring comfort to you and the earth
they're super soft breathable material
clean bamboo it's extremely breathable
and it
so a moisture and regulates temperature
to include your quality of sleep I am
someone who is constantly being
disturbed in my sleep by a sweaty neck
sweaty legs and I never even thought
that my sheets could be contributing to
that but once I got my attitude sheets
and the clean bamboo material totally
regulated my temperature brought me down
to like I sleep in a tough frozen tundra
and I still managed to sweat so I didn't
realize there were other things I could
be doing to change like my sheets so if
you're a sweaty sleeper I think this
will be something you'd be interested in
I'm there antimicrobial clean bamboo
charcoal fabric is infused with
eco-friendly and natural antimicrobial
bamboo charcoal so they are proven to
kill 99.9% of micro organisms attitude
sheets are great for sensitive skin
customers have claimed that their skin's
appearance has has improved after
switching to edited sheets you can read
the reviews and see for yourself they're
super sustainably made their
manufacturing progress is process is
designed to save energy and water while
eliminating the use of toxic chemicals
attitude makes every conceivable effort
to use recycled materials keep hashtag
packaging minimal and reduce their
carbon footprint at every step of the
process why not try attitude they're
soft as silk
breathable as linen but at the price of
cotton you're gonna love them and right
now our listeners will get 20% off their
sheet set and free shipping if you Tex
toast to six four zero zero zero so the
only way to get 20% off your set of
attitude sheets with free shipping is to
text toasts toas t26 4 0 0 0 text toast
2 6 4 0 0 0 Thank You attitude for
sponsoring today's episode let's dive
right in sign on you'll get that
attitude you'll get that gold - I love
that song ok first story the I would say
the biggest story of the day but then
something just came across my desk but
actually technically is bigger but this
is the one that we're so excited to talk
about our ship is coming in Megan Fox
feels romance rumors in Machine Gun
Kelly steamy Bloody Valentine music
video just days after Megan Fox was seen
out with rap rock artist Machine Gun
Kelly and she and her husband of a
decade actor Brian Austin Green
confirmed their split the actress is
feeling rumors of her mjk romance by
appearing in his steamy new music video
for Bloody Valentine
ok if you haven't seen this music video
you absolutely have to in it's amazing
video it's an amazing song it's an
amazing testament of their love and our
ship
that is coming in everything about it is
amazing the song is so good like this is
really the genre of music I used to be
into when I was like in middle school I
was kind of like an emo kid and I would
just like love like rock and my love of
5 seconds of summer like I really am
actually locate into that genre and it's
like pop rock and it's such a good song
she looked sickening the house down in
the music video like she looked
beautiful daily they were social
distancing I think like I think they'd
literally had one cameraman and they
edited afterwards cuz they were in his
house oh yeah I was like but there
weren't distancing from each other they
were quite close no but I think the
video was filmed in quarantine got it
well it just goes to show you like you
think you know celebrities you think
this picture of megyn kelly and MGK was
like oh my god you said megyn kelly for
sure that's their couple name Oh totally
Meghan Meghan Kelly
that's hilarious that picture of Megan
Fox and Machine Gun Kelly was like oh my
god they're caught they just started
this new relationship like this video
was obviously filmed not yesterday and
so they've been together for a while
they probably were like to bag that's
Brian Austin Green I just keep on into a
handbag every time I remember they were
probably like to bag listen we're gonna
come out with this video like you can
get embarrassed or you can release the
statement it's up to you so we put out
that [ __ ] about a butterfly people were
like what does that mean so he had to
write a plane literal statement saying
that they were separated a lot of people
feel like this relationship is like some
sort of PR stunt because like how
convenient is it that they were
photographed and now there's a music
video and I definitely see how someone
could perceive it that way I choose to
believe in their love and if I did find
out that this whole thing was fake like
I would be devastated I thought about
them all day yesterday like I watch a
video 400 times I'm obsessed with them
and you know what I kept doing more
research on them like you know I never
would have pictured them together but
the second someone mentioned their names
in a sentence like I was on board the
ship ready to set sail um but now the
more that I know about them like the
more make sense like did you know that
Machine Gun Kelly has a daughter no I
so they're both parents like you think
like she's kind of a cougar but they're
really had similar stages in their lives
like they're not that far off from each
other ya know when when this came across
my desk I thought it made so much sense
watching this video
like wow this is just like watching
Twilight I'm watching true love on my
screen and I'm completely here for it if
this came out to be a farce I would say
there just broke up and they got
embarrassed that they were in love at
the time there's like I just I've seen
so many fake couples like in my time as
a pop culture pot connoisseur I feel
like I have a very good gauge for that
thing and I don't think that the will is
being pulled over my eyes like I believe
in their love does that sound so naive
I mean it will only sound that you
depending on what happens you know if
they turn out to be the greatest love
story of our time like you were just a
believer and this they break up people
will say it was fake so I think just do
what feels right for you I believe in
their love too there's no reason for
them to have gone together like why
would he choose to have a PR stunt with
a married woman you know this is
involves a family like because she had
to come out with a divorce at the same
time as she was gonna announce this
relationship like I just think that
that's too far gone to be a stunt that's
true there's a lot of discussions being
had about whether or not this was like
an affair and like how could we ship
them if they were having an affair but
it's my understanding that her and Brian
Austin Green like haven't been together
for a while they were always on and off
on and off messy messy messy um so I
don't feel like an affair is really what
happened here maybe that's also me being
naive but I could just they're kind of
private like they obviously announce
when they're going through stuff but we
don't know their Instagram stories every
day if they've been living in the same
house for the last few months like I
actually think they probably haven't
been together for a little while and
weren't gonna announce it yet but she
got in a new relationship and that kind
of was the catalyst for the announcement
I completely agree with you it's been
messy messy messy like I know people
want to say it's an affair how could we
[ __ ] um it's just not my business
so I'm just gonna take the parts that
were given to me they got divorced in
the next day there was a music video to
me that's not an affair no and do you
think that um and because we're in
quarantine like there's so much that we
don't know because it's been like almost
three months of like things going on
that we're not aware of but do you think
that if it was an affair Brian Austin
Green would have taken the opportunity
to say that on his podcast or he's not
about to disparage like the mother of
his children not about to disparage the
mother of his children and mate I'm sure
he's got some [ __ ] that
did wrong - so you don't start like
throwing she's firing shots like that
especially with the mother of your
children yeah I don't think it was an
affair but I understand that people do I
choose to believe in their love and ship
this so hard harder than I've ever
shipped anything before I choose to
believe that Brian Austin Kelly released
a statement saying they were getting
divorced
and then Bobby Austin Kelly Brian Austin
Green now you're thinking Brian Kelly
the points guy like you need to get your
names right these people have too many
names between three people between three
people we have eight names it's hard I
agree i jusu foofy that Brian Austin
Green released his statement and then
like 10 minutes later they started
shooting his music video no I honestly I
would I Megan Fox's Instagram in the
last time she posted with her husband
not that she's so active but the last
time she posted was for charity in
November 2019 they were like auctioning
off something for one of those things um
so I actually don't think they've been
together for a while yeah I don't think
so either
so I choose to ship but to each their
own um not to totally change gears but
I've been getting a lot of DMS people
want asking me if Cassie and Colton are
still together and it reminded me that I
haven't seen them like be social being
active on social media in a really long
time and then some of us like they
unfollowed each other and I checked and
they did not unfollow each other like
that's how rumors get started but they
haven't really been that active with one
another in a while I I think they might
have separated in quarantine like I
think he might have went home or
something interesting which would make
sense
I mean couples who are just dating and
quarantined now together for 70 days I
was actually thinking about this last
night with Olivia culpo and Christian
McCaffrey she and her sister have been
quarantined with his entire family this
whole time and I just can't believe it's
going so well like this bodes so well I
think they'll be married in a year like
they're married now she's you know they
wasn't in LA with her her sister and
Christian and then they went to the
parents like two days they did the first
weekend and then they've been there the
whole time while they've been together
the entire time like they are true love
I know it's like a long time to spend
with someone's prospective in-laws
I know with your sister there to like no
privacy it's really interesting yeah
honestly I hope that like the sister is
getting some it's like one of Christian
McCaffrey's hot-ass brothers so there
were some rumors and snitch and I had
our own thoughts I definitely think
there's some flirtation but I don't know
if it's like if they've kissed yet yeah
because they're like in the parents
house I think they have to be respectful
yeah but you know quarantine can do
crazy things to a person crazy things to
a girl
okay next story the other big story of
the day Laurie Lachlan and Massimo Jian
newly agreed to plead guilty in the
college admissions case Laurie Lachlan
in last mile Jian nearly have agreed to
plead guilty to conspiracy charges
connected to the college admissions case
according to an announcement from the
Department of Justice Thursday morning
under the terms of the agreement which
is still pending a judge's approval
Laurie will serve two months in prison
and Massimo will serve five months the
DOJ said in an announcement
Laurie will admit to one count of
conspiracy to commit wire and mail fraud
and Jia newly will plead guilty to one
count of conspiracy to commit wire and
mail fraud and honest services wire and
mail fraud do you think that there's any
possibility they only took this deal in
the hopes like strategically that
because of karna virus they might not
have to serve the time like they could
do it from home or something I think
that coronavirus played a major factor
in them taking this deal I think that
this deal might have not been offered to
them outside of the pandemic I think a
lot of different factors went into this
but we are at this place now due to the
circumstances of the global pandemic and
I think ultimately it's worked out in
their favor because people were talking
about like up to 40 years for them if
they were found guilty when they pled
innocent so what I think this is like a
win for everyone the Justice Department
like it's a guilty verdict you know they
two months in five months especially if
those sentences are made shorter due to
either you know prison capacities or
coronavirus I think this might be best
case scenario for everyone yeah I mean
the prison that um Felicity Huffman was
in the facility that she was in was like
a camp
um and she did 14 days um and she got I
think she actually ended up doing like
eight days and I'm curious if this is
gonna be the same facility that Lori
Loughlin goes to I don't think that it
is because Lori's trials were being held
in Boston so they're all they're all
held in Austin because the case is in
Boston but Felicity Huffman --zz prison
was I think in California yeah I don't
know rule do you go to prison based on
where you live or based on where the
crime was committed I feel like it would
be based on where you live yeah I don't
know but I do think they would probably
go to the same prison um but that all of
the cases for this operation varsity
blues are out of Boston interesting well
I'm hoping that this is gonna be put
behind Lori Loughlin she hasn't slept in
a minute like hopefully this brings some
relief to everyone involved on all sides
and everyone is just you know able to do
better yeah I think that this would be a
good way to just end this story um we'll
hear more when the judge approves this
sentencing or not um just a very
interesting development in this case
that has really swept the nation I know
like when it first came out I cared so
much like now I just don't care yeah I
would agree so much has happened since
then right it's like the world
my priorities have shifted yeah the
colleges aren't even in session right
that's funny yeah okay next story a
little update because we reported a
while back that Skeet Ulrich who plays
FP Jones on Riverdale was leaving
Riverdale and now he is explaining why
and it's just cuz he got bored in
February the shocking news came out that
Skeet Ulrich was leading CW's Riverdale
where he plays FD Jones usually actors
give politely vague reasons for TV
departures but ol Rich's gloves came off
in an Instagram video he posted
Wednesday night he said I'm leaving
Riverdale because I got bored creatively
how's that that's the most honest answer
honestly I think that
is so fair also FP Jones was really I
mean they all sort of like are these
tropes and caricatures of themselves but
like I think it's time
ya know I definitely appreciate you
always wonder like was there bad blood
did he get fired like you never really
get any sort of clarification and if you
do it's like years down the line and you
just don't care anymore so I'm
appreciating that in real time update of
like the show is definitely not what it
used to be I don't think it's
challenging anymore for a veteran actor
like skeet and I appreciate this
different kind of transparency and I
totally get and respect um like not
wanting to do it anymore like not being
sequestered to Vancouver when your life
might be in where ever he lives you know
yeah I agree and you know it so they
just finished the fourth season and I'm
reading that the season 5 will be pushed
forward a few years into the future
which makes sense because like they
should be going to college now or
whatever and no one needs to see that
that's always like a painful spot for
high school television shows right so
this is actually a perfect time for
people to leave the show because in the
few years that we miss like maybe they
went off to their own thing maybe the
character has passed away a lot of
different things can happen yeah this is
like the classic turning point in a lot
of teen dramas it's like the actors are
too old to be playing kids like just
going to college second of all it gets
so complicated whenever it's like split
up and go to different colleges like
they did this in um Pretty Little Liars
like it's always like that weird like
high school dramas to me are the perfect
template for television except when it
comes to graduation it's like what do
you do so a lot of people go for the
let's skip five years and I kind of
liked it they did one of those skip five
years and Desperate Housewives and at
when I remember watching it in real time
I was like this sucks and then whatever
you watching I'm like this was brilliant
yeah like a lot of shows do different
things I remember the OC like they
actually did follow them into college
but then also they brought up a new crop
and you always hope that you know the
junior cast will become the new main
cast I don't think that's ever happened
in the history of television it's not
her mom Broyles no it's not Gossip Girl
did a pretty good job cuz they kept the
characters in New York City for college
but then we had to watch Blair go to NYU
which was just like so painful oh I
read a bunch of Twitter conspiracy
theories absolutely rooted in no facts
but I thought it was an interesting take
that a lot of people felt like the
banner pump rules finale was a series
finale and I don't like I don't see any
proof of that but like the way that they
entered it and kind of broke the fourth
wall with Lisa talking about the TV show
with two jacks and like reprimanding him
people felt like it might be some sort
of series finale I don't think that at
all I didn't get that vibe and if that
is a series finale it was a good season
finale for that season because the
season was not good but if that is a
series finale that does not do justice
to the entire like seasons of shows that
we watch like less we offer yet this
used to be an amazing show I know but
the prospect of Vanderpump rules being
over like did kind of bring me joy like
I'm just so over it yeah that's an
interesting prospect that it would just
be over but I think there's more to be
milked from it I do I don't think it's a
completely water cause but sometimes you
just want to quit while you're ahead
but yeah Joe's never do that some people
were thinking that like it was similar
to on the hills when like they walked at
the end and it was a movie set like they
thought it was like a similar trajectory
of like Lisa finally breaking the fourth
wall addressing the fact that there was
actually a TV show happening and then
like all the couples going off like I
don't know it wasn't big enough and whoa
when it was happening the series finale
he was like Sheena 2.0 and Anika getting
in like the weirdest fight of all time I
just I'm so many batters the best fight
of all time that was the best moment of
like the last four seasons was just cuz
we've been so deprived yeah you know
yeah um okay ready for our next week's a
little sad no no NIC Cordero's wife
breaks down in tears as she reveals his
condition is quote going downhill NIC
Cordero's condition has taken a turn for
the worse according to his wife Amanda
klutz
though the Broadway star expected
experienced a small win in his recovery
from coronavirus related complications
earlier this week his health began to go
downhill on Wednesday morning she shared
in a tearful update on her Instagram
story quote NIC has had a bad morning
unfortunately things are going downhill
at the moment so I'm asking again for
all the prayers
mega prayers right now she revealed
explaining to followers that she won't
be able to appear on her daily Instagram
live video please cheer and please pray
for Nik today and I know that this virus
is not going to get him down it's not
how this story ends so just keep us in
our thoughts and prayers today thank you
oh my god I'm literally gonna cry I
thought we were out of the woods I know
he did have a win um but I guess it just
they weren't completely out of the woods
and now it's taken turn for the worse um
and I just feel so sad for them I know
and her newborn and she's just been so
positive like I can't even imagine being
in that situation and then like
radiating hope and positivity for the
entirety that she's been going through
it and I feel so sad for her oh my god I
thought this was over like I thought we
were good I thought he was like getting
out of the hospital soon
yeah his virus [ __ ] sucks like
literally sucks sucks oh my god I'm so
sad well I will be praying for her
husband I like oh my god this is
terrible I have nothing else to say
besides like I'm just devastated I had
no idea I thought this was totally over
oh yeah no I saw it and I think
yesterday like just some stories that it
had starting to take a turn to go
downhill and it just made me so sad and
just wanted to update everyone because
we had updated everyone on the good news
and so this is now the latest update but
I'll just switch gears again to a good
story okay because the masked singer
season three winner will put their
trophy right next to the Grammy okay
spoiler alert
I'm issuing a spoiler alert suppose I do
not watch the mass singer but the way
that publications and people go out of
their way to not spoil this show I think
is so impressive
I never even know who's on it I didn't
know who won it because I didn't click
this article until you told me who won
it and of course this is news that is
personand to the situation but I'm just
so impressed by the way no one will
spoil the show and I'm not gonna be the
one to do it for you so spoiler alert
I'm about to tell you who won the Fox
singing competition had a franchise
first with Wednesday's champion who
talks with The Hollywood Reporter about
stage fright quarantine entertainment
and why'd the series is less stressful
than her other reality job the masked
singer crowned its third combat third
champion on Wednesday with its first
woman to win the competition
and thick and Nicole Scherzinger
correctly guessed the identity of night
angel Real Housewives of Atlanta star
kandi Burruss so fabulous I love a
moment for reality TV like it's a win
it's a check in our column um there I
didn't even realize the season was still
airing because literally months ago I
saw people guessing that it was kandi
Burruss I'm like oh it probably is she's
a Grammy award-winning songwriter she
sings all the time she has tons of music
I thought it was for sure her and I
thought the season was over like months
ago I heard that kandi Burruss might be
one of the contestants so long ago I
can't believe this show is still on yeah
crazy I mean the runner-up was Jesse
McCartney oh oh it's an interesting show
I don't watch it but I'm always
interested in the news that comes out
about it and also all of the speculation
like I know a lot of people thought this
season that Liz Gillies was on it they
thought Jordan Woods was on it was she
on oh there were some people last season
who thought I was on it I got like
messages about if I was a flamingo did
it wind up that Jordan Woods was on it
yes okay cool I'm Cody Simpson won the
Australian partially yeah I remember
that cuz oh him was judging and she like
asks for her couch back or something
yeah yeah I mean the concept of the show
is so silly and I remember initially I'm
like writing it off completely but
people really fell in love with it so I
started to watch it the episodes are so
drawn-out it is an hour where four
people sitting for four minutes like it
is so much funner so many commercials so
many dumb segments like and the costumes
like it's so silly and it's like the
concept is fun like trying to guess
someone and like you think it's so easy
but there could be such a familiar voice
and you really don't know who it is so I
like the concept is good but I could not
get into it like it was literal trash
for 45 minutes five minutes of content
and then 10 minutes of commercials like
it was just too much got it
well I liked it and finding out this way
and I love this her kandi Burruss she's
just another notch on her belt she's
just still like the most accomplished
housewife of all time and this is just
one more win yeah and you know what I
feel like this is really gonna create um
like a bigger divide within the women
because a lot of the the especially as
it pertains to Nene
I think for a while she thought she
would never have to come back to Atlanta
housewives like she was in Ryan Murphy
shows she was in glee she had a pilot
the new normal like um and she even
moved to LA for a period and like kind
of was so nasty to the women because she
thought she was better than them and in
that moment she was but kandi has really
always been like one of the most
successful women in the Atlanta
franchise and she doesn't hold it over
the other woman's heads like she's
really very like grounded in her success
and I think this is gonna throw a wrench
in it like some mainstream successes
name he's not gonna be happy about this
yeah well I love to see it
me too I'm like over Nene she was really
bothering me but I'm I have a soft spot
in my heart for her so I'll allow it
me to him me too okay those were five
stories and and you definitely need to
know them I'm so sorry I didn't know we
were on the fit and final strike aside
something to say before I do you mind if
I have a moment sure take your time
because today's episode is brought to
you by grub hub download the grub hub
app order and get started you can
explore restaurants that deliver near
you it's so easy to find food you crave
and order through the grub hub app you
could search by cuisine restaurant name
or menu item the app will help you
filter your results accordingly they
help you enjoy your favorite restaurants
with new perks and exclusive rewards you
can get a $10 perk every time you water
it's available all day every day at
select restaurants you can stay safe
while also supporting the restaurants
that you love at slash local restaurants
with curbside pickup and contact free
delivery on grub hub your day just got
better so make sure you use those $10
perks on every order whether it's
breakfast lunch or dinner and just for
our listeners if you download the grub
hub app you'll get $10 off your order of
$30 or more every day from participating
restaurants that's $10 off your order of
$30 or more every day from participating
restaurants so download the grub hub app
today and get $10 off your order of $30
or more love it wow that ad just made me
so hungry I think I might order some
grub hub for lunch because I'm starving
what'd you eat for dinner last night oh
I had noodles and cottage cheese Oh YUM
I had that luck the other week it's so
cottage cheese is hard to keep in the
house because it literally expires in
like four days but once you have it at
the prime of its life it's so good it
was so good I needed a big dinner like a
big bowl of pasta to edit my video I
literally haven't had a chance to eat
since
my breakfast and so I just needed a big
portion of carbs ya know the redheads
for you was a big cow catcher in your
day um no I mean I had planned for it so
I don't know that it was a picture was a
cow catcher like you just weren't
expecting it to take so long no and it
was a cow catcher and I use the word
correctly and I went I think I think the
editing for me was a cow catcher in your
day you didn't realize how long it was
gonna take for me no um I don't really
concern myself with things that don't
concern me so like related to TN n
podcast so it's true actually that's
true but I'm not involved in the editing
I'm just more of a managerial partner
here you know it was a cowcatcher for
sure yeah I mean sure on the opposite
day it was a cow catcher oh you you did
not just opposite opposite Davey how
[ __ ] old are you I mean I'm just
factual for sure so mine that's why it
was a cow catcher okay well definitely
check out the redheads to find out
whether or not it was a cow catcher in
my day that's a great promo yeah um so
I'm gonna talk about Ben pot special
really quickly if you'd like to mute it
or I could speak in general terms um I'm
gonna mute because I want to watch this
with open eyes open ears and open heart
with no preconceived notions we talked
about on the redhead size and I thought
like the worst thing is like when people
hype up something and like your
expectations for something become so
good that you can't even enjoy it cuz
you're just like waiting for that thing
that you expected and I just want tabula
rasa clean slate wait I just muted
myself instead of turning my volume down
okay so Ben plots Netflix special I got
into bed I turn the lights off like I
wanted the full theater experience Ben
was still working in Ben sauver loves
Ben Platt and I wanted him to watch with
me but I just couldn't wait for him to
get into bed like I was just too excited
so I dim the lights and I have to say
from the moment it started it was really
beautifully done like the lights the set
the Radio City Music Hall is such a
beautiful place and I feel like Netflix
really did a good job of like respecting
the institution if that makes sense
um Ben plaid himself was just beyond you
know your wildest expectations like his
talent is so real and I wasn't surprised
at how talented the
as a singer he was because to be honest
I already knew that but I was really
surprised at his kind of stage presence
you know he's such a small person but he
had such a big personality and he was so
funny between songs and also kind of
earnest and he loved that he explained a
lot of the songs I was never really sure
if the songs on his album were written
by him or like songs that other
songwriters wrote and they just like put
Ben Watts name on it cuz I know that
he's like a theater kid but I don't know
if he's a songwriter and him explaining
the songwriting process I'm just what
the situation's were behind the scenes
that inspired a lot of the songs really
made me excited um I was watching the
whole thing and I'm like is he not gonna
sing in case you don't live forever
which is a song that is like so special
to my heart and like all my sisters like
we all really connected over that song
because it's how we feel about each
other and his parents were in the
audience and the song is about his dad
and it was just so so lovely and I
literally just started sobbing like
uncontrollable you just start thinking
about all the people in your life who
you love so much and if anything ever
were to happen to them like what would
you do I started thinking about my dad
like it just it really got to me and it
was so beautiful and so emotional and
the craziest part was that my husband
Ben went to the same Jewish camp as Ben
Platt they have two versions of the camp
one is on the west coast one is on the
East Coast
Ben's offer obviously went to East Coast
Ben Platt grew up in LA he went to the
West Coast camp but the two camps would
converge on this trip to Israel and
that's where they all got to know each
other both the both coasts and so that's
where Ben software met Ben Platt and Ben
Platt was talking about a trip to Israel
where a kid accidentally outed him and
was just like Oh Ben plot is so lucky
that he gets to he's so lucky that he's
gay because he gets to hang out with all
the girls and it wasn't meant in a
derogatory way but someone accidentally
outed him and I literally was screaming
oh my god get in there was this you and
he was like no they were in the eighth
grade and Ben didn't go to Israel with
Ben flat until they were 16 and then
also he was talking about another
situation at camp where one of his bunk
mates was named Ben and he stole his
copy of Harry Potter and I'm screaming
I'm like Ben was that you and he said no
they weren't in the same camp they were
never in the same bunk they just took a
trip together to Israel when they were
16
so unfortunately Ben saw her was not a
part of Ben Potts special but that
didn't make it any less fabulous he was
really
great I can't recommend it enough I
actually watched it twice back-to-back
because I loved it so much so that's
that on that let me get Jackie's
attention we're good
she's taking pictures of ourselves
you're good to go
would you stop taking pictures of
yourself your sister's going to jail
everyone what we're going through I need
to turn my air conditioning on I'm
sweating from talking about Ben plot so
just say something um wait you can't
drink your a/c on because of the noise
so that's what I'm gonna say we also
need to recap song land I saw that you
watch it and I'm so excited by the way
my air conditionings on every day in the
podcast but my I don't know how to turn
off my air conditioning it's on a
schedule to go to 85 degrees at like
11:15 every morning I don't know how to
get it off so at some point in the toast
I always start sweating um but it
doesn't affect the audio this this is
way oh okay cool yeah I don't hear it
okay song land Oh song land such a good
episode I love Florida Georgia line
they're like my favorite guys I feel
like I don't really know them that well
and I've never really watched an
interview where they talk and you get to
hear firsthand their experience and I
just love how much everyone really
respected them in the room and how they
really have changed the sound of country
music a lot of like hardcore country
music fans don't like that but I [ __ ]
love it and I just love that they were
given so much respect the song and you
know I wasn't like in love with really
any of the songs that came out usually
there's like a few that need work but
still have like that bass the the
second-guessing when they ended up
choosing was my favorite originally and
then as my favorite afterwards but I
just didn't really feel like it was a
strong competition amongst the songs um
yeah because that one was like just on
another level from the get-go and I'm so
glad that they chose it because they
really aside from Holi which I don't
know I haven't heard it in that many
weddings they don't like have such a
like big love song like that and I love
second guessing that I love that you
assume that you're second guessing me
something but no you don't spend one
second guessing I thought it was
brilliant
I liked there was another song that I
liked that guy who not the one who's
changed completely because like Ryan had
absolutely no time for his original
like hi I'm life or whatever I hope the
other guy who who song like I love the
melody like it was so catchy but he just
wasn't saying anything and ultimately he
still didn't say anything but also
whatever he said just wasn't more
poignant than second guessing but I
really liked that other song - I thought
they were all great and I love I love
ultimately the like far to Georgia lines
cut of second guessing I think it's so
good and this show is just so amazing
like it is the best reality TV
competition show out there period
there I said it I agree I might to feel
bad like the formula of the show is not
perfect because they only go from four
songwriters to three and it's just like
one person doesn't make it and I felt
bad for that girl and I felt like her
song was good but she just had a
terrible singing voice which isn't her
fault she's a songwriter she's not a
singer and I just feel like she couldn't
sell it and I think it actually might
behoove them sometimes to have just
professional singers learn and perform
the song well they do that ultimately
when it's the second round of choosing
like they bring in the right singer if
they need to um but for the first
iteration like it's really just about
the song but dad can I always talk about
like if I were an amazing songwriter say
and I went on song lands like I can't
carry a tune like what would I do
someone would have to even sing the
first version you wouldn't even know
what I'm singing if I sang I think that
you can't get on the show even if you
have an amazing song I don't think
they'll accept you if you can't like
carry a tune in the slightest that I was
actually thinking about that last night
- it was that girl who didn't get
through it like really had a bad singing
voice like not to be a [ __ ] and no and
coming from her it just sounded like a
corny song but maybe a florida georgia
line saying it wouldn't but just like it
sounded like the song in the beginning
like of a hallmark movie about joy for
country yes I couldn't agree more like
her voice got in the way of what could
have been like a sweet song and I think
maybe if someone else had sung it like
it might have had a chance cuz I thought
it was for sure more there was more to
work with there than some the guy with
the long hair and the beard I thought
that was his song was it was good it
just was not Florida Georgia line at all
yeah I totally agree the guy with the
long hair like a kid like he was shocked
he made it so far but he had really good
attitude about stuff even when Ryan
Tedder took his song threw it in the
trash inside
I love Ryan Tedder my favorite part of
the show is seeing the friendship
between Esther and Shayne I know my
favorite part of this episode was when
the last songwriter left the room and
they just started riffing on one of the
songs and they came up with an amazing
song just the five of them like there
needs to be a show of just like a camera
in the room like just every artist gets
to write with these three people like
they're so [ __ ] talented Ryan Tedder
also looks like the third member of
Florida Georgia line like he has such
FGL vibes I love Ryan Tedder like even
though he wasn't really present in this
episode he's still my favorite um
judge Esther is my favorite judge and I
also just I'd love Shane but he wins
every single time because it's always a
country artist and he always gets to
work with the first best song like the
one that is the closest to getting there
yeah there's definitely politics behind
the scene of song line that we don't
know like even from how they choose the
song writers have three out of four of
them were from Canada like I just
thought that was like an interesting
fact there's definitely more politics
behind it and I have a feeling that they
already know who's gonna win when they
come through the door I don't know if it
says organic of a process as they
pretend it is but that's TV that's like
when you watch HGTV and they go shopping
on house hunters they already have that
everybody bought the house
yeah I agree that doesn't bother me as
long as like you know the songwriters
Esther Ryan and Shane are happy and the
artists are happy and they're making
great music and I just absolutely have
the format of this show who's on oh my
god I can't stop harping who's on next
week I don't know I can't remember
someone's interests aunt damn yeah check
the Instagram make it quick I'll just
keep talking about song I'm the most
fabulous show on TV so this was
definitely one of my favorite episodes
ak was like obsessed with it he never
wanted to attend I also think the song
second-guessing would have been a great
choice for Dan and Shay it's just yes I
agree they don't have it on the cam
okay well I'm sure I'll see it later and
it's just gonna bother me until then so
tomorrow we'll recap Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills along with the new episode
airing tonight Real Housewives of New
York so if you're looking for that join
us
tomorrow if you're needing more content
there's a brand-new episode of the
redheads along with a bunch of other
Tina and podcasts there's new episode of
Margaret Joseph's this natural er mood
before in Elizabeth new episode of
Maternity live and now I am on this
episode I thought I was gonna be on it
last week but I got bumped and now I'm
this week it's a really fun conversation
staney vibes if you're into that sort of
thing so check it out you could follow
Tosa news network on instagram to keep
up with all of our new shows and if you
haven't ordered my comedy special yet it
is now available for pre-order click the
link in my bio on girl with no job
Instagram it is available for pre-order
on iTunes and I would really really
appreciate the love and support maybe
leave a nice review and that's what we
got for you guys thank you so much nope
check out our interview with Lauren
crepe you're watching on video that
interview is on YouTube right now and if
you're listening to a podcast she's
coming right up after this oh we didn't
even get to talk we spoke to her
yesterday she was literally the most
mature person I've ever met in my life I
couldn't believe like how wise as [ __ ]
she was she talked all about her
experience getting invited to be a part
of the Taylor Swift music video for the
man and she was just she's literally a
class act she's going places like she's
a star
she is it she's everything of the sort
so definitely check out the interview
out we were just like starstruck by her
oh I forgot about that yeah thank you
I'm thinking about so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennium
morning show where we'd alive Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcasts we found set Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I have radio cast
box all the places whoever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast I
leave a five star review about how
beautiful studying and smart we are we
love you guys very much and we'll see
you tomorrow for Friday Friday gotta get
down on Friday hey bye